what do writers need to know about
writing historical fiction what
historical fiction is okay historical
fiction is the history is accurate but
the story is fictitious it's not a
biography okay so your characters may
not totally totally be real and some of
it of the story is a fictitious but the
history behind the story is real the
other thing they need to remember is
that you should always keep a
bibliography to support your history and
in the back of the book good historical
fiction always has a bibliography in the
back it doesn't have to be everything
you've done but it has to be I recommend
a lot of like books papers websites and
other sources I have like his New Haven
Historical Society information from
there so different sources that you have
and then maybe a couple pages on what
was real you know what what was real
because I can remember getting texts
when people would read it and say is
this real and I said everything's real
in the history it's all real and the
story is about real Oh mmm that's what
they should know and what point did you
actually take a trip it's a new hand
I've never been there you've never been
there okay and what you do is because
everybody if after you read this it's so
full of details that nobody would guess
I'd never been there because I actually
at the 1920s New Haven green more New
Haven green the nine squares map from
the from the Historical Society in New
Haven which stores all around in 1910
and I walked through it and I downloaded
pictures I got the streets I got a map
of the streets in 1920s I have
everything and it's nothing like it was
in the 1920s but I have all the
information I need if there was a
building I researched that building if
and and also for the Yale campus see
it's right next door the L campus and I
downloaded all the buildings in the
young campus on my living room I made
the Yale campus I know all the history I
know how they were built and when I had
the main character walk through the Yale
campus I walked down the stairs of
Phelps Hall and across the courtyard to
the library and I know where the trees
are I know who everything and so I I
didn't need to go there so someone
doesn't have to plan an expensive trip
across country or the other side of the
world to be able to have an accurate
feeling of place know now what I
recommend it I'm gonna go there but did
I need it no and if I would have thought
I needed it to enhance I would have gone
but with what I did
I've had feedback the same question and
I say no and I go you did no I don't
need to and and they're surprised after
they read the book because like how do
you know all this stuff
well see I'm a professor and professors
research and when they don't find they
want they find it somewhere else
you know they look and they dig and they
dig in they doing and it was second
nature of me to do that
you